non
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui trois choses
la toute première chose mario kart 8 de
luxe ça c'est le point numéro 1 au
numéro 2 faq point numéro 3 le gâteau
jeunes explique le principe à partir
d'aujourd'hui on va essayer d'instaurer
une règle c'est à dire que je vais
essayer de faire des vidéos tous les
jours des vidéos qui seront développe
éditorialisé le principe comme tu le
sais ce que c'est qu'un blog je fais
rien apprendre on partage des choses du
quotidien par contre on va parler de
take 2 high tech alors je te l'aï déjà
dit pas forcément tout le temps parce
que ça va dépendre la pole d'actualité
donc dès qu'il y aura des choses
intéressantes à dire high tech ci a rien
à dire on prend et on en parlera d'autre
chose
aujourd'hui je vais te parler de mario
kart 8 de luxe et on va faire une autre
reine on va dire que tous les jeudis on
va faire une faq
l'idée c'est tu me pose des questions si
tu as des questions à poser si tu as
envie de savoir des choses tu me
médecins sur twitter mon twitter c'est
monsieur grrrr tout attaché et moi je me
fera plaisir de te répondre comme tu as
pu le remarquer derrière aujourd'hui on
parle de la couleur rouge c'est un peu
le fil conducteur
j'en ai ras le cul de cette pièce un peu
trop bleu tu es tu vois on rajoute de la
couleur on est du tonus faut que ça
envoie du steak et que ce soit sympa
c'est parti
rouge rouge logique
ne arrière passé gonflées hyper
dangereux donc ouais ce casser la gueule
ça va lasser corriger tes dents
[Musique]
aude
normalement quand on sait la peinture on
se change c'est quand même beaucoup
mieux comme ça dis moi ce que t'en
penses et mario kart 8 de luxe est ce
que tu as vu le lancement de dingue de
ce jeu en trois jours il s'est vendu à
plus de 1 million d'exemplaires
c'est d'algues il est sorti il ya pas
longtemps le 28 avril
tu as vu le lancement de la nintendo
sweets a été complètement dingue la
console a cartonné
elle a été vendu à des millions
d'exemplaires et aujourd'hui elle un
succès fou elle permet effectivement à
nintendo de remonter la pente parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas terribles ces
dernières années on sait qu'ils sont un
peu cassé la gueule sur lancement de
leur dernière console celle là elle est
dingue la souris ça cartonne
d'ailleurs t'as qu'à voir un il ya eu
plus de zelda qui ont été vendus
dernièrement que nintendo switch tout
simplement parce qu'elle est en rupture
encore dans plein d'endroits d'ailleurs
ce mario kart 8 de luxe c'est juste le
meilleur lancement depuis le début de la
franchise c'est un truc incroyable
rien que le premier jour il a été vendu
450 neuf mille copies
ça comprend ce qui les téléchargements
de ce jeu aux états unis c'est
incroyable alors je sais pas si toi tu
la sita ipswich on a beaucoup parlé de
la nintendo switch bien quand elle est
sortie puis même avant je sais pas c'est
à ce jeu si tu l'as dis moi ce que t'en
pense parce que j'ai pas encore eu la
chance de l'essayer
donc si tu l'a testé si tu la mets moi
un commentaire et dis moi franchement si
ça vaut le coup et s'il faut l'acheter
une statistique qui complètement dingue
et c'est qu'il ya quasiment un
possesseurs de nintendo switch sur deux
qui à ce jeu d'ailleurs on le remarque
un camp la nintendo suit est sorti il y
avait des jeux qui est annonce au
catalogue il ya des soldats qui étaient
hyper attendu mais on sait très bien on
savait très bien qu'il ya d'autres jeux
qui allait arriver derrière et les
titres phares tu le vois la console a
cartonné il ya eu ce mario kart claque
un train de cartons de tout exploser
il ya d'autres jeux qui sont attendus il
ya ce platoon 2 qui est vraiment attendu
il ya eu la démo il n'ya pas longtemps
qu'ils étaient juste dingue ici il ya
super mario dit c'est aussi qu'attendu
qui fait partie des titres elle en a dix
qui vont des titres phares et qui vont
être parce qu'ils vont faire partie des
jeux des jeux je vais y arriver
les plus vendus d'ailleurs il ya qu'à
voir mario kart sud de luxe à 93% de
notes en règle générale au niveau des
professionnels c'est un jeu qui est
super bien noté et qui est vu comme le
meilleur mario kart de toute l'histoire
donc si tu l'as si tu l'as acheté dis
moi ce que t'en pense parce que ça
m'intéresserait vraiment d'avoir ton
avis est de savoir si ce jeu franchement
vaut le coup oui ou non a priori il est
juste donne donc il vaut le coup mais
dont la vie est vraiment le bienvenu
point numéro deux je me dépêche va faire
une faq la faq du jeu ni envoie toutes
tes questions directement sur twitter
monsieur heureux comme ça au moins on
pourra je pourrai répondre à des
questions si toutefois tu en avais alors
on va prendre les quelques questions que
j'ai eu et je vais te dire je vais tout
donner mais les lots dreux
tu as quel âge c'est quoi ton vrai nom à
excédent de questions alors je vais pas
donner mon nom en entier parce qu'on
s'en fout je m'appelle aurélien aurélien
c'est mon vrai prénom gros c'est presque
mon nom de famille à quelque chose près
mon âge bas j'ai la trentaine bien bien
bien bien tassés d'ailleurs je peux pas
te mentir ça vous paraît que je blanche
et un peu j'ai 37 ans au jour
d'aujourd'hui
donc voilà pour cette question c'était
une question de hédi jul msp est ce que
quand ce platoon 2 sort ce switch des
abonnés pourront jouer avec toi please
ça sera avec plaisir sauf que en règle
générale et j'ai pas trop le temps de
jouer aux jeux vidéo je le fais vraiment
quand j'ai
un petit quart d'heure un moment à tuer
mais en règle générale juge toujours en
train de courir soit à tourner soit sur
monsieur gros point fr à écrire un
article soit en train de faire un
montage directement pour le veloppe
toujours toujours un temps qui est
extrêmement content et donc j'ai très
peu de temps pour jouer et c'est vrai
que le reste du temps que j'ai je le
consacre à ma famille à mon fils et à
justin
voilà donc c'est vrai que si si je joue
à ce plateau 2,6 geste platine 2 à
l'avenir il ya très très peu de chances
qu'on prie souvent ensemble désolé c'est
fait la deuxième fois qu'on me dise un
lacet à lysine l'idéal ce que je tutoie
l'idéal serait de vous voyez vos
interlocuteurs
en france le tutoiement n'est pas
respectueux alors je suis désolée elle
allie si effectivement c'est un peu de
shopping si ça choque d'autres
personnages si ça peut vous choquer je
vais pas continuer à choquer mais c'est
vrai que le tutoiement le tutoiement
pour moi permet effectivement d'avoir
une discussion plus proche on l'a moins
cette barrière du vouvoiement alors le
vouvoiement quand je l'emploie ces
pourparlers je dirais à vous tous pour
parler plus à la globalité le tutoiement
jeunes l'emploi des mots pour te parler
à tous en particulier quand je rentre
plus dans quelque chose d'un team dans
une discussion un petit peu plus
personnel alors c'est pas du tout du
manque de respect parce que j'ai
énormément de respect pour toutes les
personnes qui regardent le blog et
toutes les personnes en règle générale
je le connais assez respectueux il faut
vraiment pas mal le prendre
le tutoiement c'est vraiment dans le
sens d'avoir un lien fort avec la
communauté et pas du tout de manquer de
respect et de prendre les gens pour ce
qu'ils ne sont pas donc je tiens à
rassurer tout le monde
je te respecte énormément si là dessus
autre question qui a gagné pour voir
tous which are oui c'est vrai il y avait
le concours de tous which way to switch
j'ai voulu faire un live pour
effectivement annoncé le nom du gagnant
et puis départager un petit peu le parmi
les personnes qui ont participé
je suis désolé j'ai eu des gros
problèmes avec mon adsl sahara mais
énormément du coup j'ai préféré couper
le live plutôt qu'avoir un truc il a qui
est dégueulasse et qui est pas du tout
sa part gardé je vais leur faire très
très très bientôt je vais faire d'autres
tests pour être sûr qu'on ait
suffisamment de débit je vais faire en
4g je pense parce que là
fondamentalement en upload sur ma boxe
c'est une catastrophe donc
rassure-toi soyez tous rassurés très
très prochainement ou and to switch
il va partir l'un d'entre vous veulent
gagner donc bas qui coule je vais faire
une info très très bientôt sur les
réseaux sociaux facebook
monsieur re tweeter monsieur gros
instagram monsieur heureux et le dernier
cessna chat un chat me suivre donc
venez faire un petit tour a ajouté moi
et comme ça vous serez au courant de la
date et de toutes les infos à venir
question de césar agostini super vidéo
sur une vidéo sur l'iphone merci
beaucoup césar vous faites des vidéos
sur youtube pour le plaisir ou pour
gagner votre vie alors c'est toujours un
peu compliqué aujourd'hui au jour
d'aujourd'hui j'ai 4300 et quelques
personnes qui sont abonnées à mon point
d'ailleurs je remercie d'être tous
présents à 4300 abonnés sur youtube ont
ils pas du tout sa vie un autant de dire
que là si tout de suite je compte sur
youtube pour gagner ma croûte et puis
nourrir ma famille ça va être
relativement compliqué mais c'est vrai
que
les deux je répondrais les deux ta
question parce qu'aujourd'hui je le fais
par passion parce que de toute façon
quelque chose comme ça on peut pas le
faire si on n'est pas passionné par ce
que d'une s'assemblent voit très bien
dans la vidéo un métier pas passionné
qui fait ça en espérant bd de la
notoriété signé du pognon déjà il se
fait que dans l'oeil bien profond parce
que ça va se voir les gens n'ont pas
d'airé ça n'a pas été terrible je suis
pas en train de dire que ce que je fais
est génial mais en tout cas je suis un
vrai passionné et j'aime beaucoup ce que
je fais et j'aime beaucoup à partager
toutes mes petites découvertes et puis
toutes les nouveautés high-tech avec
vous avec toi en particulier l'argent
c'est bien quand ils arrivent pas pour
rouler sur l'or et rouler en cadillac et
être blindé faire le kéké
c'est juste pour pouvoir effectivement
passé plus de temps à la création passé
plus de temps à pouvoir faire des vidéos
de qualité et à pouvoir partager plus de
choses donc la passion est là et
j'espère qu'elle le restera toujours
si l'argent pouvait venir en eau
notamment par le fait d'augmenter en
abonnés ont monétise plus on gagne un
peu d'argent en attire des sponsors
ça me permettrait effectivement de faire
encore plus de choses et de passer
encore plus de temps sur mes vidéos
alors autre question qu'est ce qu'on a
jean faisant qu'un copain jean je sors
manger un couscous et pourtant tu me
donnes les femmes aussi fait sur une
vidéo précédente
niveau nouveau studio tu envisages
installée de la lumière j'ai trouvé les
images un peu son oui tu as raison j'en
ai je vais te montrer aujourd'hui avec
points je tourne en éclairage et tu vas
voir que c est fondamentalement pas
idéal aujourd'hui j'essaie deux panneaux
là qu'ils savent d'éclairage et qui me
paraît effectivement d'avoir un peu plus
d'éclairage au niveau de ma tronche
par contre c'est pas idéal parce que
déjà quand je bougeais pareils sont là
là là ça fait d'être l'obscurité c'est
pas terrible et c'est juste pas hyper
guitare pratique donc ce que je vais
faire dans le studio
je vais mettre des éclairages à led j'ai
déjà un plafond j'ai un truc à ne pas
donner ou qui est dégueulasse je vais m
en espèces d'éclairage multi spots à led
pour vraiment éclairé l'ensemble de la
pièce jeannotte pas lumineux vers les
lumières vote à gauche pour vraiment
éclaircir l'ensemble de la pièce avec de
la laine de la lumière blanche pour
qu'ils aient plus de lumière qu'il soit
plus convivial donc voilà j'en sois
tranquille si nécessaire et d'ailleurs
je peux en voir son passage dernière
question je crois à de doka et ses
livres tu serais pas le frère de fabien
olicard et par écoute
à moins que mes parents mes lentilles
mais sinon je crois pas mais j'aime
beaucoup famille en liga c'est un mec
qui est très talentueux dans ce qu'il
fait on mentalise à chaque fois je suis
pas son frère mais en tout cas je le
rencontrerai avec plaisir donc si fabien
te regarde cette vidéo elle n'hésite pas
pour rien et ça ce sera un grand plaisir
que je me ferais mentaliser partout
c'est tout pour ce tf1 qu aujourd'hui
n'hésite pas comme je te dis aime
envoyer toutes les questions sur twitter
monsieur grudge me fera un grand plaisir
de répondre jeudi prochain et maintenant
c'est l'instant gâteau
[Musique]
les rouges à ce film là c'est toi là
c'est moi là c'est toi tu vois c'est la
technologie là tu peux dire bonjour
on va manger un brownie les brownies les
moins chers du monde
[Musique]
thomas
m
et là tu es ou elliot et où je ne vois
pas ça veut pas dire qu'ils viennent
[Musique]
m